women are better off in 2023 than they
were in 1953
and tell me why yes or no and why
I don't think so I think this is just my
personal opinion
in 2023
you are better off
materialistically
um that's just the way Society is we
have to sort of fend for ourselves so um
you know if I really wanted to I can
work hard I can go out by Mercedes get
Chanel bag whatever but
you know
I still have to walk down the street
alone at night not knowing
what could happen you know and and like
you know the option to sit at home and
be a housewife isn't readily available
to me so I do believe that women in the
1950s were better off
just because life was simpler also like
technology wasn't around back then and I
think that
especially social media is the most
toxic thing to happen to us you know
we're we're more connected than ever
before but I think kind of what you were
saying like spiritually we're further
apart than we ever have been because
social media and and everything it's
just a front and you get to tailor that
front how you want to be perceived
um so yeah I definitely think that well
me personally I would have much
preferred to have been around in the
1950s
yeah I agree I definitely would have
much preferred to be around in that time
because you know things were just I
would say more
simple back then and just more
just I wouldn't say easier but just
there wasn't a lot of pressure you know
you you didn't have that much pressure
to prove yourself or you weren't
comparing yourself to people all the
time and you know you kind of just did
what you did to get by and you know
communities were stronger you looked
after your family and you know you
weren't distracted by social media and
you know what people were doing and what
people are wearing and buying nowadays
so I feel like we we have been like
brainwashed in a way um and I would much
prefer to be back in those days to be
honest
uh I would say
um obviously we talk about gender right
now but
um for race
um I think in 1953 like it must have
been way harder for like black couples
to um
be able to even like function
um so and then 2023 um we're much more
aware by like race and like
um the effects that like black people
have like so for me to find a lovely
black man in 2023 I feel like
yeah it will be much easier for us to
actually be in an open relationship
um
no not open over because no I want to be
in a monogamous relationship but yeah
it's what you know to even hold hands
down the street without yeah so yeah I
think 2023
can you ask the question again
are women better off in 2023 than they
were in 1953 oh no I think like they've
really influenced by society and that
they're like chasing what Society is
feeding them
and like
when they actually get there they're so
unhappy because they've realized they've
wasted their life chasing something that
was designed to destroy them
I think that was always implicated from
the 1950s even till now it's always been
fashion there's always been up our
middle and lower class so people have
always been chasing some things you know
I mean to Bear themselves so me
personally I say
it's just more in your face because
we've got access to it you know I mean
certain people that what we're now
looking at and thinking oh wow they've
got this and that there's always been an
upper class middle class and a lower
class it's just more in your face now
and we more look at it like oh if they
can do it I must be able to do it it's
just you're chasing it quicker because
it's in your face but in
aspect of like fashion and everything
nothing has really changed I'll be
honest it's just more in your face it's
just more accessible but for me
personally I'm I'm happy in 2023 I think
social media makes women more delusional
yeah it does but it's in your face
that's right it's like they start
thinking they look like the filters
I hate it after Rochelle someone message
me off of Instagram I'll look at it I'm
like what the who was that 100 it's like
they start to literally think that
they're the filters and that the
attention they get from those filters is
equates to real life and it does it but
that just as human beings we've always
looked up like there's always been kings
and queens you know what I mean like so
it's just more in your face it weren't
accessible like that like the rich used
to be around the rich the poor used to
be around the poor do you know what I
mean and if you did see rich person or
you'd look up to being that person but
it's exactly the same I'd say it's just
more in your face it's more accessible I
think that's what the company creators
are designed to do like the economy now
relies on the computer which influences
the outcome of society as a whole I
actually think women are better off
today because they have no consequences
from bad decisions I don't think it
makes us happy but I just think like
before if you left your man you were
homeless now we have all these programs
to bail us out of every bad decision
that we made so if you look at it very
true I mean I don't think it makes us
happy just like it's kind of like if you
give a kid everything they want are they
really going to be happy at 18
I almost think women are spoiled in 2022
yeah 23 that's afternoon
I forgot
you agree disagree yeah yeah
you don't think women are spoiled in
2023.
you don't oh no I think everyone they're
super reasonable oh okay that's how this
is a pretty reasonable panel but I think
it you know you said obviously like are
women better off yeah I think I think
yeah yeah I think I agree they are like
better off yeah
um my answer was more coming from like a
personal point of view of what I'd like
and you're right it's about what what
would make us happy but if you're
actually looking at it black and white
yeah you're better off like if even if
you do go homeless or whatever like
starting early fans like we have that
option now or or it's like yeah if you
get pregnant if you get pregnant they
used to have shotgun shotgun weddings
now they just have abortions wow it's
true yeah it is you know 40 of women
that have had abortions over two or more
what are they gonna have in the future
so it's literally a form of birth
control in 2023. yeah people use
abortions as birth control and it's it's
not great I don't think it's great but I
definitely think we're better off in
2023 I don't think would have been able
to do this in the 1950s sit with a
woman-only panel and discuss topics so
I'm grateful that we're here they had
some actually I've been reacting to some
yeah it's like um there was uh but were
they like as as a view yeah it was it
was well probably not as well I mean
yeah I can't imagine they had the views
YouTube that's how it is but I was
watching this debate I don't know if we
do we post the reaction of the debate of
the housewife versus the
you remember it was like a housewife
versus a career woman and it was so
interesting because it was the same
conversation we're having today but it
was literally it might have been the 60s
or like 50s 60s time frame but then
maybe it wouldn't be as diverse Maybe
I think we're better off now in 2023
yeah we've got access to more things but
it's like I think we're better off but
we're not happier yeah yeah I don't
think women the outcomes like leave us
happy and I feel like what you said um
social media the delusion I feel like a
lot of us well I speak for myself maybe
we spend so much time on social media
that we get distracted and we start
looking at what we see and thinking okay
this is what we need this is what we
should be doing this is where we should
do and in reality it's not like that
everyone's showing their highlights
nobody's showing what is really
happening yeah well and I think the
delusion is leaving us single and
childless yeah I mean who is a kid here
who's a kid you're a kid and they say 50
of women are going to be single and
childless by it's 20 30 so it's half of
us
like if we look in this room half of us
probably won't have kids
that's already sad
I hope it's not anymore but does that
make people happy and my grandma you
know it's crazy my grandma
um she she's like pretty sick so I don't
know how much longer she's gonna live
but so I've been asking her like these
like deep questions I'll get them on
video and one of them I said like do you
have any regrets in life and she told me
I wish I had more kids and I said
Grandma you had nine kids
how many did you want she's like 12. wow
but it's like when you ask girls I mean
who here wants nine kids I definitely
wouldn't mind yeah no I would have not
you would have nine kids 100 really have
you had one yet no but I have the one
first and then come back to me I don't
even need to have the one like I've
already looked after children and no I
mean child child labor
is awesome
it's nothing it's worse it's like I
don't know a thousand times worse what
are my bodies built for that it is built
for that but I don't know if you would
go nine times for that but it's it's
interesting because the conversation you
guys are having now that's like a modern
conversation because if I said that to
my grandma she would be like yeah no we
have more than nine yeah so it's kind of
it's kind of just it's a Testament of
the times definitely yeah I think I I
feel like women really wanna well
there's a lot of people who actually
want to just work so I think they're
thinking that they don't want to have
that many kids just so that they can
still have that freedom and that
flexibility
um and there's a lot of women who
actually don't even want kids as well
and there is a study that said 80 of
women are not children
so the majority of women do want kids I
think it's yeah because if I I've had
girls come on the show and they'll say
oh I don't want kids and then my next
question is well what if it was with
this guy and there's always some say it
because they they're with someone that
doesn't want kids or they just feel like
they can't be your mother or they can't
get the guy they want to have kids with
that's true and so it's almost like a
coat no I don't I don't like I mean some
girls really don't but it's I don't
think it's a large percentage of women
yeah I wonder how old those women are as
well the women who say that they they
don't I'd be interested to find a woman
it's like mid 30s plus you it's usually
a COPE in my yeah I actually I want to
do a panel with single childless women
over the age of 55. yeah it's hard to
recruit for that though so if the
comments want to help me in London
that's specific on the panel but just to
get their point of view because I feel
like around like 50s women get more
based a little bit where they kind of
are not like you still get the 40 year
old saying oh I'm gonna have three kids
like when
yeah menopause is coming